[Music]
how's it going everyone we had a chance
to see the division 2 which now takes
place in Washington DC and it is a
bigger game because how big is it
according to the developers they said it
was about 20% bigger than Manhattan in
the original game so they're focusing
more on you know serves a variety of
environments you'll explore so you'll
you'll still have the in verb urban and
residential areas but also you'll be
going out into forests and maybe the
sort of the flooded under grounds of
Washington DC yeah they said it had
something like six biomes as a compared
Askim biomes that's a good word the last
one I think the last biome was New York
and New York and underground New York
underground this one has things like
force full enforced this time around
they have flooded flooded districts
financial districts they have the center
of governments but that's not the only
thing that they're changing this time
around so they said they're trying to
focus a lot more on the endgame
experience
they said specifically that they want
players to be able to you know sort of
see the end in sight you know so they'll
always be aware trying to you know reach
that end goal of trying to get more loot
and get more powerful so it does seem
like they want people to sort of clear
through the campaign as quickly as they
can to actually get to the true or game
I guess you can say which is unlocking
the unique specializations that each
character can unlock if the demo that we
played actually was right at that point
it was at the point where that where you
had just transitioned from level 30 into
the endgame and you started picking up
signature skills and signature weapons
so we saw a crossbow and explosive
crossbow a grenade launcher and a 30
caliber sniper rifle and each of those
weapons has unique skill trees attached
them so you're also you know going in
and unlocking different functions for
those like different weapons but also
you know boosting up your character as
well it was interesting so we actually
have to play a bunch and the game feels
it feels like an upgraded version right
now of the previous game we didn't see
anything that was drastically different
it was definitely that classic
cover-to-cover shooting it was a little
bit spongy it was it was very difficult
which I appreciated we like having demos
at e3 that are actually hard to get
through like a bunch we wiped once or
twice yeah there were some things that
were a little bit more immersion
breaking the last time like last time I
was shooting dudes with hoodies hundreds
of times and this time run we were
shooting bald guys hundreds of times so
this faction was referred to as the true
sons which looks far more dangerous than
any other faction we've encountered they
have foam guns that we saw them they
basically trap us in like you know sort
of foam like you know it's sort of like
it's about Ghostbusters or something and
we can't move and you got to shoot like
your allies out of the foam to actually
get them to you know come out of it so
it's a it's weird but at the same time I
feel like the setting itself is just way
more interesting than Manhattan because
for one there's a lot more history you
know this is a you know the nation's
capital you know you're seeing a lot the
familiar like American iconography like
the Washington Monument and you know
numerous museums in the area also you
know in terms of just the variety of
environments
it just feels much more visually
interesting than Manhattan and also it's
during a heatwave so you know people are
gonna be running around sweating a lot
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be weird
tell me a little bit actually about the
people in the environment well the thing
about this game is that there's a lot
more focus on rescuing civilians because
those civilians will actually be able to
help you during certain conflicts like
uh during one section where we were sort
of fired fighting the true sons faction
they call they called in a heavy then
one of our partners fire to a signal
flare which hauled in the civilians and
they had their own arms and you know
they're able to help us out they didn't
really go too much into it but they were
a part of the settlement system which
from what we understand you basically
capture a point on the map then you'll
be able to recruit any of the civilians
you've rescued throughout the game and
have them stay at that settlement and
you'll be able to have a base it seems
like that'll keep you in the game more
than the or more attached to the world
and the echoes did in the previous game
they didn't say that the echo
weren't in the game but they did say
that you'll actually be playing with
characters this time around rather than
just their remnants which i think is
really cool yeah you'll actually
hopefully be able to see your impact of
your actions in the world yeah I'm
definitely interested in seeing how sort
of like familiar division style events
are gonna play out one thing they did
say that we of course didn't see was
that we're gonna be able to experience a
sort of eight player raids and that's
kind of a big deal but you know I'm
excited to see how that plays out yeah I
mean much larger than last time yep and
I guess the overall question is is all
the stuff they're adding is bigger
better yeah it feels like it's
definitely gonna be a more extensive
game this time around they actually did
also confirm there's gonna be a dark
zone yeah so yeah raids dark zone
characters in the world that you
interacting with we're pretty excited
for whatever comes next for the division
hopefully a beta or something in the
near future but stay tuned to consoie
comm for more coverage of the division 2
at e3
[Music]